hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled rapid development of
multiplex
serological assays for kobit 19
beyond this webinar is part of the
ongoing coronavirus
virtual webinar series i'm susie valdez
of labrutz and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
luminex for more information about
luminex go to
www.luminxcorp.com
now let's get started before we begin
i'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you'd
like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left
of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational
and offers free continuing education
credits click on the continuing
education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
without further ado i now present
today's speakers
dr steve angeloni senior field
application scientist
at luminix and dr nicole pecora an
assistant professor in pathology and
laboratory medicine at the university
of rochester medical center for complete
biography
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
mr angeloni dr angeloni and dr picora
you may now begin your presentation
welcome both of you
yes thank you for that introduction and
welcome to our presentation
as you all know the world was turned
upside down at the beginning of 2020
and it all began with an outbreak in
wuhan china that was detected by
chinese health officials there in
december of 2019
where they are observing an increased
number of severe pneumonia like cases
shortly after that in early january
scientists confirmed that this was due
to a novel coronavirus
in early january the chinese released
the sequence of that virus to the world
as january progressed cases in the in
the us started to pop
up and in wuhan china the epidemic got
so severe that wuhan had to be closed
down
and people were ordered to stay at home
it started to spread into europe
where the who decided that it was going
to be a global health
emergency then in february one of the
first molecular diagnostic assays in the
u.s were released by the cdc
while it got off to a bumpy start it
became one of the front runners in
determining whether people had
coronavirus
in early march the who declared this as
a global pandemic
and then later in march the u.s declared
national emergency
the stay-at-home orders and shutting
down of many businesses
by the beginning of april it became
apparent that serological assays were
also going to be important
and one of the first cleared serological
assays was a lateral flow technology
by celex that measured igm and igg
titers
after that a number of serological
assays were also developed and approved
for
um screening for chromovirus antibodies
and we'll look at that
later in addition as the month of june
progressed
um there's more actually more than seven
million up to eight million cases now
that have been confirmed globally
and the death toll is climbing well
above 400 000 and climbs every day
and every week so what are coronaviruses
well coronaviruses are a branch of the
ribovirus lineage
with cobit 19 being a new sarge variant
like the other star's variants it has a
genome that's a plus rna strand genome
of about 30 000 nucleotides
transmission is spread mainly by
aerosols which enter through the lungs
and like sars virus and a number of
other respiratory virus
it exhibits zoonotic transmission
allowing it to be transmitted between
different animal species
so technologies for studying the virus
and looking at it spread through the
population
include looking for the viral rna
by molecular methods then there are some
proteomic applications
some can look for the presence of viral
antigens but it's becoming
increasingly important to look for the
antibodies against viral antigens
so let's look at some of the technology
used to do these types of measurements
we're looking for viral rna rt pcr
chemistries are the best way to go
the cdc's rt pcr test kit is one example
a number of other companies have
developed quicker assays for individual
analysis
such as the isothermal assay from avid
and a number of other isothermal assays
have been
developed and approved one by rutgers
university
the rutgers university institute for
health actually has a nice list of other
molecular assays that can be used for
detecting the viral rna present in
samples
luminex also has a couple of platforms
for looking for viral rna
the next tag chemistry can look for mers
the sars cov2
as well as the stars from the 2019
epidemic
they also have an aries platform that
has a simple sample to answer
chemistry for looking at sarge cov2
for detection of viral antigens sandwich
capture assays are
the best way to do that while these can
be used in situations where the viral
genome is probably not going to be
picked up by
pcr methods this kind of chemistry can
be used to try to detect
viral antigens in the food supply in the
mail on various shipping containers
as well as in a variety of biofluids and
tissues
it can also be used to monitor domestic
wild uh stock
livestock and other animals that might
be imported or exported
however it's also useful for looking for
serum markers
because one complication of infections
is a cytokine storm this is a severe
inflammatory response
not only to coronavirus but other
pathogens that can complicate the
recovery of patients
so being able to track and manage the
clinical progress
of treatments with patients undergoing
cytokine storm
storm would be a significant advantage
in the clinic
there's actually a luminex assay that
can do this it's a bio-red
27-plex cytokine assay on a bioplex 200
instrument
it was actually used already in china to
monitor the
management of cytokine storm and covet
19 patients
as this 2020 paper uh describes
what's become increasingly important is
the need for detecting
antibodies against the different viral
antigens
these can be used for a variety of post
pandemic immunosurveillance applications
because if as expected antibodies
generated against the virus
can provide protection then we want to
be able to screen individuals that have
been
infected and have survived so that we
can probably give them clearance to
return to work
without the concern of them spreading
the virus for being susceptible to the
virus
this would allow us to do immune
surveillance of various populations in
the healthcare industry
military and other essential workers
that can return to work
there's a diagnostic alternative to
looking at you know the presence of the
virus
in cases where the virus might no longer
be present it can also give us the
ability to look at high-resolution
analysis
of the titers of different ig isoforms
during or after an
infection it can also help us monitor
the variants that are circulating
through different populations
and then immune to compromised patient
populations it could also help us
monitor their ability to develop a
defense to the disease
by generating antibodies or not in the
research front it can be used for a
number of applications to study the
epidemiology
clinical applications and ways to
monitor the
prevalence of that the antigens and the
development of antibodies in populations
as a resource management
as far as developing uh treatments such
as vaccines the development of
biologicals and in clinical trials
the assays can also be used to look at
the immune
immune immunogenicity and efficiency of
the various vaccines
for convolution plasma and immune
biologicals it could also be used to
test those
compounds as well as monitor the quality
of their manufacturing
and then in subject trials it can be
used to qualify subjects with regards to
existing titers as well as qualify
how well the treatments are working
so a number of serological assays have
already been approved by the fda
a number of them look at only the spike
protein but can look at either igg
and some can look at igg and igm a
number of
applications have developed that look at
only nuclear capsid
antibody responses and these can also
look at either igg
or igg and igm one of these applications
has been developed on the luminex
platform
currently there's uh one pro one assay
that's been developed that can look at
spike and nucleocapsid antibody
production
and that's on the cellx lateral flow
technology that can look at both igg
and igm so luminex is actually poised to
be able to take these tech
these approaches and do them in a
multiplex fashion not only for a variety
of proteome
applications but for genomic
applications as well
and this can be done by the fact that we
have the ability to multiplex on the
luminex platform
this is achieved by having sets died of
different colors
so that each color bead set can be
assigned a different analyte
so for example this would be an example
of a hundred plex assay
with these four particular bead regions
being specific for these analytes
for coronavirus this could be a
nucleocapsid spike protein
a receptor binding domain and maybe some
other variant
in that mix and if you wanted to you
didn't have to run all
100 different bead regions for 100
different analytes you could run just
these four if you wanted to
by doing this we have the ability to mix
up to 100
500 different bead regions in one
reaction allowing you to mix
up to one look at look at 100 and 500
analytes or more
in one reaction and this can be done in
either a 96 well plate
or depending on which instrument you
have a 3d4 well plate
so the power of this multiplexing
ability has several
features first compared to singleplex
reactions
you can use less sample and less
reagents you require less time and labor
to process
the assays it's going to be less
expensive you get more data faster
it's also more flexible because you can
easily add or take out
bead regions for different analytes at
will it gives better
reproducibility as will enhance
statistical power
compared to planar spotted arrays the
bead stand suspension which gives you
fast
fluid kinetics in suspension that helps
you measure the analytes more accurately
as opposed to spots on the bottom of a
well that can interact with
analytes that have to be mixed
thoroughly and maybe have cross
fluorescence that can this that can
cause
blending out or bleeding out into other
bead regions or spot regions on a
spotted array so a good example of the
power of this multiplexing ability is an
example of a hundred and seven flex sas
we ran for one client
where we had 14 samples that we ran in
triplicate
with the luminex platform we could run
this in 42 wells of a 96 well plate
where if we tried to do this with a
standard single plex chemistry
it would have required almost four and a
half thousand wells which is equivalent
to
about 47 96 well plates
so this approach has already been used
to study coronavirus titers
for example in this paper from 2019 this
group looked at the antibody titers
against nucleocapsid protein
from six coronavirus variants they ran
almost a
600 samples and in doing this study they
were able to see at least 80 percent
correlation with regards to picking up
positive fighters
for the specific nuclear captured
samples had in them
and on the negative samples we had also
about 80
or higher correlation with regards to
correctly identifying negative samples
so if this particular assay was put into
the clinical field
and you say you wanted to look at 1000
samples with this six flex
virus assay on luminex this would have
required about a thousand wells which is
equivalent to about 10 96 well plates
if you did this with a standard
singleplex chemistry this would have
required almost 6000 wells
or about 62 96 well plates
if this was going to be done also say
with a lateral flow type technology
it required 6 000 lateral flow
cartridges
as opposed to still being able to do it
on only 10 96 well plates with the
luminex platform
so let's look at how to build an
indirect serological assay on the
luminex platform
so you have two options one of the first
options is the standard option of being
able to couple your proteins directly
by the fact that our luminex beads have
carboxyl groups on them which when
activated with edc
will react with amines on your proteins
this can be done pretty simply and
doesn't take that much time only a few
hours
the first step is activation the
carboxyl group through edc
and stabilizing it with sulfur nhs which
takes about 20 minutes
followed by an incubation of your
protein with the activated beads
this can take anywhere from an hour to
several hours where your protein will
then be covalently
coupled to the bead so
coupling large proteins such as the
spike protein is fairly simple
the spike protein has a lot of lysine
residues which provide those free amines
for
linking to the activated carboxyl groups
coupling smaller domains or smaller
antigens
is also fairly easy because of the large
number of
lysine residues that proteins will have
in them coupling of peptides however can
be trickier
some peptides may have no lysines for
few lysines
as in the example of this particular
peptide it does have three lysines in it
the way it folds the presence of these
lysines may be in pockets
which cause a protein to be coupled in
an orientation which will not let you
detect antibodies
term you know being reactive to specific
epitopes on this
particular peptide in scenarios like
this
where the carboline diamond
carbodynamite coupling is not going to
be feasible
we have another option which is you can
biotinylate
either the n-terminus or the caboxii
terminus of your peptide
and then use some beads that we sell
that have avidin coated on them
then select for each peptide a
particular bead region you want that
peptide bound to
and you can incubate that peptide for
about 30 minutes with its specific bead
region
do several washes and within under an
hour you now have peptides are going to
be
tightly coupled to your avidin bead
since the kd for this biotin avidin
association is 10 to the minus 15 molar
this is almost as good as a covalent
coupling
and can be done rapidly and allow you to
develop assays
fairly quickly so here's a bunch of tips
that you
will need to use when developing your
assay first of all
while the genome for the coronavirus
encodes a number of enzymes and
non-structural proteins
the proteins usually used in these
antibody tighter assays include the
spike
the nucleocapsid and the number of
people are starting to use the spike
receptor binding domain
when selecting these antigens keep in
mind that you can couple either the
whole proteins
you can use specific domains or you can
use peptides that are representative of
specific epitopes that you're interested
in
in some scenarios you can use virus-like
particles as well
but the virus like particle beads are
usually not as stable as coupling
these other forms of the proteins to the
beads
and so these other forms of proteins are
better to use for assays that you need
to be stable
to use over a longer period of time
when selecting your antigens you should
also know your antigen
well when purchasing antigens from
standard off the shelf suppliers
you want to verify the protein sequence
that's the one you need
because there can be variants out there
and some proteins while well conserved
some have divergent sequences that will
not be suitable for the performance of
the assay
so knowing what sequence you are getting
can be important
for developing a reliable assay when
using whole proteins or domains
that are expressed in different
expression systems the expression system
you select is also important
you want to make sure that number one
that the expression system can generate
sufficient amounts of proteins hopefully
at an affordable cost
in addition to that the antigens are
folded properly
and if any specific post-translational
modifications are necessary
that they're properly modified as needed
for performance in the assay
so the other thing is that when proteins
are generated in these different
expression systems they will have
different tag sequences that will be
used for purification
some of the properties of these tag
sequences are important because you
don't want
tag sequences that can react to
antibodies in the serum sample
or react with the detection chemistries
that you're using
so this includes things like various fc
domains that are used
in various other domains that come off
of other viruses that could interact
with
your serum sample or some of your
detection reagents
when choosing these antigens if
off-the-shelf ones are not suitable for
your application
there are vendors that will make custom
proteins for you
so this can usually be a little more
expensive and takes a little longer time
but if you need a very specific sequence
that's not available
it is an option also when determining
detection reagents to use
there are a number of antibody sources
out there and sometimes it can be
difficult
to pan those sources and determine which
ones you need to try
generally if some are not defined in the
literature as being very good
universally
you'll need to try some from a variety
of sources and there's a variety of
online tools that will help you find
various antibody vendors as well as
protein sources if you need control
proteins
and this white paper about needing
antibodies for your luminex assay
is available for you to look at these
sources
so once you've got all these reagents in
hand building an assay requires three
steps
the first is coupling your antigens or
binding your antigens to avidin beads
the second is confirming energy coupling
this will require antibodies that are
specific for each antigen
these can be molecular or polyclonal and
they can be unlabeled
and if they're unlabeled of course
you'll need a second detection antibody
that can be either biotin labeled and
then using sape or it can be pe labeled
in some situations if you don't have a
monoclonal or polyclonal that's
available
you can use strong positive serum
samples to determine if antibody
coupling is present
when doing that you want to test that
with a strong positive serum
and define negative serums just to make
sure you're actually seeing specific
signal
once confirmation has been confirmed the
next step is assay optimization
this requires testing a combination of
sample dilutions amount of detection
reagents
incubation times and conditions to
determine the optimum
conditions needed to ensure
accurate sensitivity and accuracy of the
assay
when doing these confirmations or
running the assay itself
it's a pretty simple process it's a
matter of taking either individual beads
with their own antigens
or beads different beads with different
antigens and running them in a multiplex
mix
in this case this would be equivalent to
a two plex assay
where you then take your bead mix you
mix it with the sample containing
antibodies
those antibodies if specific for the
antigen will bind to that bead
and then you come in with your antibody
detection reagent
which in this case is say an anti-igg
that's biotin labeled
that will then bind to the other beads
and if you want to you can pick
igs that are specific for either ig
subtypes
or the igg that you're interested in and
then this will bind to the antibodies
you can come in with sap for this one
and then in each well of a 96 well plate
this can then be read in one of our
luminex instruments
where each well is going to be a similar
sample measuring multiple antibody
titers depending on how many different
beads
you have in there with the different
antigens with up to 500 maximum
now if you want to look at different ig
subtypes in this type of assay
then each sample would require
additional wells with the detection
reagent specific for that ig class you
want to measure
processing of the assay can take
anywhere from just a few hours to
several hours
depending on the sensitivity and how the
assay was designed
that generally will encapsulate taking
your beads mixing with sample
for a specified period of time doing
several washes adding the detection
reagent
several more washes and then reading one
of our instruments
so this type of approach has already
been used with the luminex platform for
a number of different pathogens
not just the coronavirus that we looked
at earlier it's also been used in a
variety of animal model systems
to look at the presence of titers
against various animal
animal viruses and other pathogens in
bovine livestock
and various companion animals it's also
been used in vaccine testing
that is exemplified by this measles
mumps rubella
paracel study here
it's also been used in uh as immune
surveillance
in this case studying of a population
exposed to different malaria
parasites
so santa body titers have also been
developed by a number of
uh partners that we work with both
academic
as well as corporate and some state
laboratories
one of which is the university of
rochester in rochester new york
there's central laboratory and dr pecora
has data on that
dr pakora i'll turn that over to you
hi thanks steve yes i'm going to jump in
for a few slides and talk about
the covid19 serological assay that we
have developed here
in our clinical diagnostic laboratory on
the luminex platform
so this assay is a five-plex assay
of the five bead regions three of them
are coronavirus specific so
we purchased all of our antigens from a
commercial supplier
in this case it was genscript the three
coronavirus antigens we used were the
full spike protein that was expressed in
insect cells
we also used the rbd by itself the
receptor binding domain
as well as the nucleocapsid protein
expressed
in e coli the rbd and nuclear capsids
were coupled at equimolar concentrations
in this case both 100 picomoles per
million beads
whereas the spike was somewhat lower at
10.
we also included two control beads we
have an igg control
which is simply a different bead region
that was coupled with
total human igg and we use this to
monitor the addition of anti-igg
detection reagents
and finally our fifth bead is an
instrument control bead which is
internally dyed and is there to
basically monitor the
machine performance
so to bring this assay up and to develop
it we had to optimize a few different
aspects once we had the antigen
we had to assess different antigen
coupling concentrations
to confirm the coupling we had to
assess a few different antibodies from
commercial sources
to be sensitive enough to detect that um
once we had our bees coupled and the
coupling confirmed
protocols are worked out we had to then
assess
a good detection antibody so we looked
at several biotin labeled or
pe directly conjugated anti-human iggs
and then of course we also had to
optimize the
serum dilutions we were going to use in
this case we ended up picking
one to 2000 which equates to about 10
microliters of total serum input so it's
you need very little serum for this
assay
and then finally once those things are
optimized for the assay itself we ended
up
deciding on a combination of biotin
labeled anti-human igg
along with sape but we add them together
in one step so that having the two
separate reagents allows us
to pretty to fine tune in order to
minimize background and enhance
sensitivity by adding them both together
we then make it a more efficient
assay to run and in a clinical
laboratory
the speed of the assay and the
efficiency is is obviously
quite important so this slide cartoons
the general workflow of the assay
once the serum is alloquoted the whole
workflow is about 45 minutes
so this includes an incubation step
where we incubate the
bees along with the serum for 15 minutes
at 37 degrees
we wash it two times each wash is about
two minutes
and then we incubate with our detection
reagents together as i said before in
one step
so that's another 15 minutes two more
washes and then we
read it on the flexmap 3d platform
once the plate has gone through all that
and is red then
before we even decide whether or not we
will look at the patient samples we
assess all of the controls so there are
several controls integrated
in each plate these include negative
negative sample controls including both
pbs
tbn so just buffer as well as igg
stripped
human serum there are also two positive
sample controls we incorporate on every
plate this includes a low positive
patient and a high positive patient
and then as i said a couple slides ago
we have our human igg coated bees
and our internal control beads so for us
to accept this plate and
and to look at any of the patient
samples all of these controls have to be
within range
um if any of them are out then the plate
is not is not
accepted we we established the ranges by
running many hundreds of samples through
the validation procedure
um in order to to get all of those
quality control
criteria uh determined
so once all that was established then
our next question was to decide how we
were going to threshold and
uh differentiate negative from positive
calls
in going into this assay our biggest
concern really was specificity
even more so than sensitivity so
although we are in new york we are
actually in a region of somewhat low
cova 19 prevalence
going into this we estimated our
prevalence was probably about three
percent
based on some serious prevalence work
done by our public health laboratory and
also our molecular diagnostics
numbers and so with a prevalence at
three percent
um a specificity really needs to be as
close to
100 percent as possible in order to have
a very
high positive protective value um
as mentioned here so clearly 97 percent
you're at the three percent prevalence
your your ppv is quite low so
again our goal was to get as close to
100 as possible
to assess this we used a set of pre-2020
serum so we had this banked in our
clinical laboratory
and it has been sent to us for a variety
of diagnostic regions i'll go
through that in the next slide and then
after running through these samples we
set our thresholds for
s rbd and n separately that were all
above any sample in that pre-covet set
so that's what i'm showing on this slide
here so our we chose our pre-covered
serum
to address a number of different
conditions which are known to
have potential cross-reactivity and
immunoassays
these include serum from patients with
positive ana titers
dmv ebv lyme rheumatoid factor and
syphilis
as well as serum from patients with a
known acute respiratory infection from
you know other viruses as well as many
serum from patients
whose serum was submitted to our
laboratory and it was negative for
anything that it had been tested for
so by going through about 215 samples
this is the data we got so in the
columns on this slide
i'm showing you the average mfi across
that group
and in parentheses i'm showing you the
maximum mfi because that is how we
threshold
based on the maximum and what you can
see is that for the most part a lot of
the average background was below 200
but in a few instances the maximum got
quite a bit higher than that this is
specifically true on the nucleate capsid
so if you
look at that column you can see that in
a few of the different groups
the maximum value started to approach
2000
and it wasn't really a continuum it's
that most of the samples in that group
were
somewhat low and then there were a
handful that were that were higher
and so we thresholded in order to recall
all of those negatives
once that was done then we then we
turned our attention to
assessing positive values so to do this
we had 125 serum samples from known
stars kobe 2 pcr positive patients
which we batched by days from symptom
onset
and we did that by doing a chart review
on on all of them and so
our days from symptom onset uh bins are
shown in the first column so we're
looking at zero to five days six to ten
eleven to fifteen sixteen to twenty and
twenty one plus
and the data i'm showing you in each of
these columns is
the percent positivity in that group
so for example in the zero to five days
from symptom onset category
in the luminex assay 44 were positive
for spike
28 percent were positive for rbd 36
were positive or nucleotide and our
overall
um luminous positivity was 48 um and i'm
sorry i should have mentioned before
that we considered an overall positive
result
uh one that was positive for any of
those so you just needed one out of
three
we compared that to another eua approved
assay that we run in our lab the avid
architect
which showed on the same set of samples
of 32 percent positivity
if we look at 6 to 10 days we see the
luminesces showing 68
positivity the abbott was 54. and then
by 11 days on the two assays were
actually quite
equivalent um becoming essentially
indistinguishable by 16 days where
they they plateaued at around 92 percent
of our stars kovi to pcr-positive
patients
so in conclusion for on my section we
found that the sars cov2 multiplexed
assay was highly sensitive and specific
and compared quite favorably to the
abbott architect cma
e-way method which we think is also
extremely good the results are highly
reproducible between runs and users
for our clinical lab that's very
important i mean we found that it really
was sufficiently robust for clinical use
and i should point out that actually
this
assay was our first luminex essay we
brought the technology in specifically
for this assay so
we found that it was compatible with a
clinical
environment and one of the things we
really liked about it and one of the
reasons we went to it is because
we really wanted the ability to
customize the antigens
to allow for flexibility as we all know
knowledge about the immune response to
stars cov2
is evolving rapidly and we wanted to be
able to be fairly nimble to address that
furthermore the large dynamic range of
the assay allows for us to develop
quantitatively to assess you know for
example donors have convalescent plasma
and to monitor recipients of both plasma
and vaccines
um the assay i showed you today was
validated as a qualitative assay but we
are intending to validate it further as
a quantitative
and with that i'm going to turn it back
over to steve and
i'll be happy to accept any questions at
the end
thank you nicole so
as we progress through this pandemic
this type of assay
can still have use as we go into the
post-pandemic phase
for one thing as it spread globally we
started to see that the symptoms for
people with coronavirus resemble flu as
well as pneumonia-like infections
so as a result it's possible that you
know there could be a small population
that if they turn up positive or
negative rather for say
the pcr assay they may have infections
caused by other pathogens
so having a serological assay you know
that can look for these other pathogens
which could be
viruses you know or bacteria could be a
benefit in the clinic
so this will allow us to also you know
kind of monitor um
you know what is happening in the
patient populations
um you know how many of them are truly
coca-19 versus
being the result of other pathogens
and as we start to move into sort of the
this later phase of the pandemic
and as you know second waves start to
occur
again having a multiplex assay that can
look not just for
copin 19 but also some of the other
coronaviruses
could be beneficial as things wind down
or as we move into
phases of second rounds of infections
so this approach however can also be
used for other types of diseases
which have similar clinical symptoms but
are the cause of different pathogens
for example hemorrhagic fevers these can
be caused by a variety
of fat viruses and in some cases
bacteria
in addition some chronic syndromes can
also be caused by a variety of different
viruses bacteria or micro
microbiological pathogens
so while the x-met technology as we
talked about earlier can be used for a
variety of applications
proteomic and genomic for this
particular application of looking at
serological uh
factors and immune responses to various
pathogens
this can provide a strong a powerful
tool for both the clinician
and researchers to follow up how
pathogens are
different pathogens are affecting
different populations all the clinical
ramifications
and the development of good treatment
strategies for these diseases
so with that we'll start to take
questions
for uh individuals who are interested in
learning how to
go from their singleplex assays
multiplex assays
so thank you for your time and we'll
take any additional questions now
thank you dr angeloni and dr picora for
that informative presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
our webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we have quite a few
questions already coming in for our
speakers
dr angela dr kakora what antigens would
you like to see
in a multiplex serological assay
i can i can take a shot at that question
um
generally for for clinical use i mean
this really does differ by if you're
running a clinical assay or a research
assay for a clinical assay we want to
see antigens that are
both informative towards a particular
disease
as well as those which might indicate
cross-reactivity with something
close or something that's related
so for example for the covet assay
we used multiple antigens in order to
threshold high enough on each of them to
get high specificity and then
have additional antigens to allow
sensitivity so
the multiplex really gave us the best of
both those worlds
whereas someone in a research or a
vaccine background
may want to add even more in order to
get specific information for
a defined epitope
thank you for that and our next question
if available
off the shelf kit would you use a
luminex
multiplex serological assay
in the clinical laboratory yes um we
would be interested in using that
research labs also want them but a lot
of research labs like to build their own
thank you for that um we have great
questions coming in and again a thank
you audience for
for submitting these great questions um
does luminix have the covid19 antibody
beads
yeah um we don't make them specifically
and sell them
that is dependent on the researchers
themselves
uh you know picking their own antigens
and
doing the coupling themselves which is a
pretty easy process
we are working on a clinical belt kit
but as far as i know right now we are
not generating specific beads for
purchase
thank you for that our next question is
your lab
a clia lab and do you have to validate
your assays
as ldt i can take that one our lab is
the clia lab so we are a full clinical
diagnostic laboratory
um and yes we did validate our assay as
an ldt similar to the molecular assays
there is um both the fda and in certain
states there are state-specific
regulations
in many cases there are streamlined
validation plans that are
covet specific in response to the public
health emergency
and in new york state we validate it
according to
what was asked for by our state agencies
thank you dr pakura and here's the next
question
interesting how likely are we to
experience
um oops i
i just lost it i apologize uh i believe
the question was how
how likely are we to experience another
second wave
and um how would that i apologize it
just got deleted
um
go ahead question about how likely would
it be um to experience a second wave i
was trying to answer that one
on uh the answers there i asked for
verbal
okay um okay i guess
yeah nicole can take that from a
clinical perspective i think
so i think the short answer is i
i don't absolutely know but i think
everyone is expecting
some measure of a second wave um to
occur and that actually brings up a lot
of interesting questions
um because it's still very much an
area of active interest what it means to
have anti-stars kobe 2 antibodies
if they translate to immunity if that is
just in the short term if that's in the
long term
these are very important and active
questions
that no one really has answers to yet so
what that will mean
in terms of the use of these assays
ongoing is
that it will as we know more about that
it may be able to help assess
whether there is immunity once that is
established
or whether or not it's durable as time
goes by and we go into a second wave and
maybe beyond
then there's going to be more of an
interest also in igg
and igm as we know more about the
likelihood of reinfection all those
questions
are going to be very pertinent but right
now i feel like we're still at the very
beginning
and we don't have answers for any of
those questions yet but they will all be
active thank you dr pakura
and this quick next question is actually
directed to you
and thank you again audience members for
your great questions coming in
um tetracore as a luminix partner has
flex m array stars cov2
hopefully i said that correctly human
igg antibody tests
that is notified at um to fda
will we be interested in comparing this
test with your ldt um i think we could
have a conversation about that
offline um so i could find out more
about it
okay perfect um our next question
are there any resources provided coven
19 antibodies making calibrate
curves for a quantitative assay
yeah nicole's trying to do that so um
that might be a good one for her to
handle
yeah so as i think as i i ended my last
slide by saying that
yes it's currently validated as a
qualitative assay
um but we are in in the process
of developing as a quantitative assay
is that entirely straightforward because
there's a lot of interest in actually
translating that to
a quote unquote classic tighter number
which is a little bit less clear than
simply giving a quantitative result but
yes that's where we're going now
thank you for that and dr angeline dr
pakora which
luminix commercial partners are
currently developing covid19
serological multiplex assays
yeah i guess i can take that question um
so actually tetracore is one of them
and they've been asking a number of
questions there about the
presentation we also have
luminex is also internally looking at
developing some acid and assay as well
and we have some state labs that
are in addition to nicole's the
wadsworth center has developed an assay
uh one of the state labs in new york
which is not really commercial that's
being used of course in state
and mount sinai is also developing an
assay
as well as a few other academic
institutions
we also have a number of pharmaceutical
companies that are using it for
other applications to test either
vaccines or
biologicals that they're developing for
the treatment of coronavirus
and those are more internal so i really
can't give you any details on those
thank you dr angeloni this next question
is for you dr pakora
do you see the use and need for igg
cytotyping assay for your clinical needs
i don't i don't know that that is going
to be a clinical
a clinical assay i can see it would be
great interest for both research
and for vaccine development but at this
point
i wouldn't see that for clinicals
thank you and we have time for a couple
more questions
does luminex have the coven 19 anti-body
beads
yeah so again the answer to that is no
at least not for sale
um we are building an internal
assay kit um that will be used for a
clinical diagnosis
um that's still in the works but if you
want to
you know generate an assay and you want
beads with um you know
some covet 19 antigen on it or another
viral antigen
um you know we can assist you with uh
building that type of assay
and as i you know uh outlined in the uh
presentation
the steps in doing that are pretty
simple um it can be done fairly rapidly
i mean it took us uh how long nicole to
develop your assay
um about three weeks and then a few
weeks for testing
if you want to summarize that there
nicole
yeah i think that was about the timeline
um
we um the commercial source that we use
transcript the proteins that we bought
from them
um fortunately were of high quality and
so we didn't have to
try multiple suppliers so since we
had a good supply up front it was fairly
smooth
thank you both and what serological
assay
are you currently using and how does it
meet or not meet your needs
so if that's um for the clinical
laboratory we
do use the avid architect assay that i
described in my presentation
it's based on nuclear capsid like many
commercial assays
are and it's quite good
and the specificity is also extremely
good but because
we are we want to get our specificity as
close to 100
as possible we use both assays together
um
and also the the ldt luminex assay
allows us to address
antigens other than n so get it that
gets us into s and rbd
thank you for that and our final
question for today is your
interest in covid19 serological assay
development focused more on
clinical or research applications
obviously ours are very clinically
oriented we do
work with a number of we're an academic
medical institution
so we do work with a number of research
groups um
in our community but our primary goal of
bringing this aspan was clinical
diagnostic
yeah but and there is our side
questions yeah because yeah sorry on the
research side
um you know there's also going to be
researchers that uh
want to expand into maybe looking at the
titers in different populations
not just of coven 19 but of other
coronavirus variants
you know to sort of do that amino
surveillance
and in some situations it might also be
useful
sort of on the research side maybe a
much more on the clinical side
about other respiratory pathogens so
like as we get into the fall
and especially if there's no vaccine
available
you know maybe a serological method that
can look at
you know the titers to various uh
pathogens that are involved in flu
versus pneumonia you know on the
research side could be useful um
nicole can comment on any usefulness of
that on the clinical side though
if she wants to
thank you both for your presentation oh
good
afternoon no i was i was going to i was
actually
difficult to say um how to use that
clinically
ongoing other than um clinical in an
epidemiological way straightforward but
for a diagnostic way
it's a little bit less straightforward
but um
go ahead i was just going to thank you
both for your presentation
and clearly your important research that
you
both provided do you want to provide any
final comments for our audience before
we close
just to thank everyone for attending and
great questions
uh yep same here uh thanks for attending
and uh
thanks for the good questions as well
thank you dr angelo and dr cotora for
your time today
and before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today as well
and for their interesting questions
i'd also like to thank our sponsor
luminix for sponsoring today's webinar
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed
by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through the end of the year
2020 libraries will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time stay safe
have a great day bye